تستعد مراكز الاقتراع في تركيا الى اغلاق
ابوابها بعد نحو ساعه من الان لتبدا
عمليات الفرز للانتخابات الرئاسيه التي
يتنافس عليها ثلاثه مرشحين بينهم الرئيس
الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان كلام او كمال
قال خلال ادلائه بصوته ان الربيعه قادم
الى بلاده فيما اتمنى اردوغان وخلال
الادلاء بصوته بان يتم فرز الاصوات دون
مشاكل
[موسيقى]
اتابع العمليه الانتخابيه منذ ساعات
الصباح الاولى وابلغني وزير الداخليه ان
العمليه تسير بلا مشاكل كان من المهم ضمان
استمرار عمليه التصويت في المناطق
المنكوبه بالزلازل فهناك من سيدلون
باصواتهم بحماس كبير واتمنى ان تمر عمليه
الفرز مساء بلا مشاكل
وادعو جميع المواطنين للادلاء باصواتهم
حتى الخامسه عصرا لاظهار قوه ديمقراطيه
واشكر وابارك للجميع
لقد افتقدنا جميعنا الديمقراطيه افتقدنا
لان نكون معا ونحتضن بعضنا البعض من اليوم
سيتغير وجه تركيا سياتي الربيع الى هذا
البلد اقدمه لكل من جاء واتلى بصوته عميق
الحب والاحترام
مجاهد بيرينجي عضو لجنه المركزيه العليا
في حزب العداله والتنميه في تركيا ان
العمليات الانتخابيه تمر بامان لاسيما
وانا وعي الشعب بالديمقراطيه يضمن سير
الانتخابات بلا اي عقبات
العمليه الانتخابيه تتم بسلام وهدوء
ونتوقع ان تتم هكذا حتى نهايه اليوم الوعي
الديمقراطي الكبير لدى شعبنا التركي سيدمن
سير العمليه بدون اي عقبات في تاريخ
الديمقراطيه التركيه لم يحدث ابدا اي
عاقبات كبيره او احداث امنيه استفزازيه
وهكذا سيكون الامر في العمليه الحاليه
تركيا دوله مؤسسيه ومؤسساتنا الامنيه على
اهبه الاستعداد لتامين عمليه الانتخابات
والتصدي لاي محاوله اختراق او تزوير او
اضطراب تجربتنا الديمقراطيه عريقه
كما اوضح احد المراقبين الاتراك ان توقيت
العمليه الانتخابيه هذا العام جاء بوقت
افضل من السابق مؤكدا اللا خروقاته او
خروقات سجلت حتى له
نسبه التصويت في هذه الانتخابات مقارنه
بالانتخابات الماضيه افضل بكثير
الانتخابات الماضيه كانت تاتي وقت العطله
الصيفيه والاجازات لكن توقيتها هذه
الانتخابات افضل الى الان لا توجد هناك اي
خروج في هذه المنطقه هناك هدوء جيد
والامور تسير على ما يرام حتى الان
المتابعه ينضم الينا من اسطنبول مفرد
العربيه الطاهر بركه ومن هاتاي عبد القادر
خربوش اهلا بكم معك طاهر الاجواء الان
والمشهد الان كيف يبدو قبل ساعه تقريبا من
اغلاق مراكز الاقتراع
اهلا خالد وبالمشاهدين طبعا اقل من ساعه
قبل اغلاق صناديق الاقتراع نحن انتقلنا
الى ثالث مدرسه وصلنا اليها اليوم في
اسطنبول ويمكن ان تشاهد من خلفي لاننا
منعنا من الدخول الى داخلها ولكن سمح لنا
بالوقوف في خارجها يمكن ان ناتي لكم
بالصوره باقرب ما يمكن لكثير من الحشود في
الواقع من الذين يتجمهرون في هذه المدرسه
ما هي هذه المدرسه التي اتينا اليها
ولماذا خالد هذه مدارس امام خطيب التي
يدرس فيها الائمه والخطباء في تركيا من
تخرج من هذه المدارس ولنكون دقيقين ليس من
هذا الفرع يعني لانها تملك فروعا عديده
ولكن من ثانويه امام خطيب الرئيس التركي
الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان درس في امام خطيب
وهناك من يقول يعني معلومات تتحدث عن انه
الثلث اعضاء حزب العداله والتنميه درسوا
هذه المدارس
ويمكن ان نلحظ يعني صبغه من هذا النوع على
طبيعه الامور هنا في هذه المدرسه مدرسه
امام خطيب التي جئنا اليها وفيها حشود
كبيره وفيها الناس يهرولون قبل انتهاء
ساعات الاقتراع يهرولون للادلاء بصوتهم
رغم اننا كنا اعتقدنا بانه العدد الاكبر
صوت في الفتره الاولى من النهار الا انه
لا تزال الاعداد تاتي الى هذا المركز
للادلاء باصواتهم هناك رغبه حقيقيه
بالتعبير عن ارائهم بغض النظر عن هذا
الانقسام الحاصل بين هذا المرشح او ذاك او
هذا التحالف او ذاك الا انه لا شك بانه
كما قيل لنا حتى من المسؤولين الاتراك
الذين تحدثنا عنهم رئيس بلديه اسكودار حيث
صوت الرئيس اردوغان اليوم وكذلك احد
المشرفين والمسؤولين الانتخابيين على هذا
المركز الذي نقف بجانبه قالوا ان النسب
الاقتراع يعني لا تقارن باكثر الانتخابات
السابقه حتى وان ساعات يعني سالته بناء
على ما يحصل احيانا في عدد من الدول
العربيه في الانتخابات احيانا تمدد ساعه
الاقتراع قال لا هذا هو القانون ولن نمدد
ساعات الاقتراع عند الساعه الخامسه سنقفل
صناديق وتاخذ العمليه مجراها الطبيعي
المعلن عنه فيما يتعلق بنقل الاصوات
بفرزها ونحن يعني استدراكا لذلك سننتقل
بعد قليل الى مقر حزب العداله
والتنميه في اسطنبول هو المقر الرئيس حيث
مررنا من جانبه قبل قليل وبدات بالفعل
التحضيرات على قدم وساق
لاحتواء مناصري حزب العداله والتنميه هناك
كما عدد من الاحزاب والتحالفات الاخرى
الذين يجهزون ايضا وعدد من الزملاء هناك
اصلا وستتحدثون اليهم بطبيعه الحال اي
اقصد ان تتحالف الامه او المعارضه
اوغلو الكل بانتظار ساعه الحسم ساعه الصفر
لاعلان النتائج
التي ستكون بدون شك مفصليه بالنسبه الى
تركيا منها ايضا ينضم الينا عبد القادر
خربوش وكذلك انضمت الينا الان زميله فاطمه
فهد منفدات العربيه الى انقره
هاتاي ماذا تقول الان او لمن ستصوت وهي
المدينه المنكوبه من الزلزال هذا الملف
الذي سيؤثر بكل تاكيد على حضور وفرص
المرشحين في هذه الانتخابات
نعم خالد هاتاي سوتت رغم انها مكلومه
سوتتها تايل رغم انها منكوبه صوتتها تاي
رغم انها خاليه من سكانها عادوا اليها من
الولايات التي يعني نزحوا اليها عادوا
اليها بقوه هذا ما كان مفاجئا منذ الساعات
الاولى لصباح اليوم شاهدنا يعني اقبال
كبير على مراكز الاقتراع وسط الدمار هذه
المراكز التي قاومت ردات او هزات الزلزال
الذي ضرب المنطقه
فقدموا وانتخبوا وادلوا باصواتهم وقالوا
كلمتهم في هذا الاستحقاق الرئاسي الهام
جدا قبل ساعه من اغلاق مكاتب الاقتراع خفت
الحركه بالمراكز ويبدو ان الاعداد قلت
بشكل يعني ملحوظ جدا صرنا يعني نعود
الوافدين بالناخب
بالواحد ولا اثنين يعني فهذا يدل على ان
ساعه حسم النتائج يعني لم تعد طويله وبعد
الساعه الخامسه سيتم غلق مكاتب الاقتراع
لتبدا عمليه فرز الاصوات ومع ذلك يصل بين
الفينه والاخرى البعض للمشاركه والادلاء
باصواتهم نذكر فقط ان من يشاركون في هذه
الانتخابات ياتون من المناطق بعيده
بالاضافه الى من هم يعيشون في الخيام
والبيوت الجاهزه ومختلف المخيمات المنتشره
في محيط هذه الولايه المنكوبه لمن يصوتون
ولمن ترجح الكفه لاحد يمكن ان يعلم
النتيجه لحد الان رغم ان نحن نشارف على
بدء عمليه الفرز الا ان الاراء كانت
متباينه ومتقاربه على الاقل هنا في
المناطق المتضرره من الزلزال على عكس
التوقعات التي كانت سابقا كان هناك
استغلال كبير سياسيا لازمه الزلزال
بالتحديد من قبل المعارضه لانتقاد الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان وحكومته في طريقه ادارتهم
للازمه وما وصفوه بالتقصير اتجاه
المتضررين والوصول متاخرين بالخصوص خلال
الايام الثلاثه الاولى لكن راينا ايضا
مؤيدين وقالوا بان الحكومه لم تدخر جهدا
حتى وان تاخرت خلال الايام الثلاثه الاولى
الى انها عادت واستدركت وان الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان قدم كل ما استطاع تقديمه من
مساعده للمتضررين وايضا قدم وعودا بمشاريع
ضخمه لاعاده اعمار هذه المناطق
المتضرره وتعويض كل المتضررين بالسكنات
بالتحديد لذلك لا لا لم يبدوا اي مخاطره
وفق ما ذكروا لنا بان يتخلوا عن الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان لاكمال ما لهم به في حين
ان معارضي
اردوغان يرون بانه فشل على الاقل في اداره
هذه الازمه هنا بمناطق الزلزال ولو ان
الرقم الانتخابي ونسبه الاعداد الناخبين
في مناطق الزلزال ليست بالكبيره جدا
مقارنه مع العدد الاجمالي اكثر من 60
مليون ناخب من يعيشون في مناطق الزلزال لا
يتعدى عددهم تسعه ملايين ناخب مسجل اي ما
نسبته حوالي اربعه عشره في المئه ولكن
تاثيرهم سيكون كبير جدا بالتاكيد بالخصوص
مع الارتدادات السياسيه التي لاحقت الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان في المدن الكبرى
والموجه الجديده من الجيل الجديد الذي
سينتخب لاول مره ويقدر عدد ناخبيه وهم
الشباب باكثر من اربعه ملايين ناخب خالد
فاطمه ماذا تقول انقره
خالد يعني بدات تخف او يخف الازدحام على
مراكز الاقتراع مع قرب اغلاق ابواب
الاقتراع على تمام الساعه الخامسه مساء
يعني دخلنا قبل قليل الى اللجان المشرفه
على عمليه الاقتراع وقالوا بان نسبه
التصويت وصلت في هذا المركز تحديدا ما بين
85 الى 95% من الناخبين وصلوا وادلب
باصواتهم طبعا في تمام الساعه الخامسه
تغلق تغلق الابواب ولكن يبدا اللجان من
الداخل والعاملين في مراكز الاقتراع
بالادلاء باصواتهم بعد ذلك يقومون بفرز
الاصوات وسنتابع طبعا هذه العمليه معكم
تباعا الى ان نصل تمام الساعه التاسعه
مساء والتي المفترض ان ينتهي فيها الصمت
الانتخابي وفي تمام ربما الساعه 11 يبدا
اعلان النتائج والكثير من المحللين يقولون
بانه ربما ستحسن من الجوله الاولى خصوصا
بعد خروج محرم انجي وتوجه جميع الانظار
لصالح اردوغان او الاصوات لصالح اردوغان
ويعني
[موسيقى]
طاهر من خلال يعني متابعتك الان ونحن امام
ربما اخر ساعه قد تكون حاسمه في توجه
الناخبين لمستقبل تركيا في انتخاباتها
الاكثر تعقيدا هي الاكثر حساسيه واهميه
ربما يتغير شكل تركيا وشكل المنطقه ايضا
في حال فوز المعارضه تحديدا بعد عقدين حكم
فيها اردوغان الكلمه الحاسمه في هذه
الانتخابات هل ستكون لاسطنبول باعتبارها
للخزان
للانتخابات والاصوات ام لناخبين الجدد من
الشباب ومن النساء ام لهذه المدن المنكوبه
التي تاثرت من الزلزال برايك سريعا
خالد هناك يعني كل هذه العوامل يمكن جمعها
في بوتقه واحده لكي تعطينا صوره عن هذه
المعادله التي تريد ان تصل اليها اسطنبول
طبعا نتحدث عن احد عشر مليون ناخب من اصل
اكثر من خمسه عشر مليون يعني قاتل في
اسطنبول او تركي في اسطنبول اضافه الى
يعني اعداد اخرى يمكن ان اتحدث عنها عن
الناخبين الشباب الذين ذكرتهم فيما يتعلق
باكثر من خمسه ملايين يصوتون للمره الاولى
هؤلاء يعني عناصر مهمه جدا ولكن كلهم
مجتمعون بدون شك سيعطون ويفرزون النتيجه
النهائيه سواء انتهت من الجوله الاولى
للرئاسيات او اضطر تره التركي الى
الانتقال الى جوله ثانيه في هذه الرئاسيات
وهنا نقطه مهمه من يفوز في البرلمان قد
يؤثر كثيرا في الاسبوعين المقبلين ريثما
تاتي جوله الاعاده في الثامن والعشرين من
مايو عدد كبير من العوامل يلعب دور لا
يمكن القول بانه اسطنبول لوحدها تقرر نحن
نتحدث عن 11 مليون ناخب ولكن من اكثر من
يعني نحو 64 مليونا واذا كانت نسبه
الاقتراع تصل الى 90% اذا نتحدث عن 58
مليون ان يقترعون في اسطنبول 11 مليون هي
الاولى هي خزان بشري هي جامعه شامله
لمختلف الاطياف والشرائح نعم ولكن يعني لا
يمكن ان نحسب انها الاكثر يعني هي من
الاكثر تاثيرا ولكنها لكننا لا يمكن ان
نحسب انها الوحيده هناك مناطق اخرى مهمه
جدا ايضا وعوامل اخرى تؤثر على كل تركيا
وليس فقط على اسطنبول فيما يتعلق بعنصر
الشباب عنصر الاقتصاد موضوع اللاجئين
موضوع العلاقه مع الغرب العلاقه مع روسيا
الى ما هنالك من كل الاتهامات القاسيه
التي كان يسوقها كل طرف للطرف الاخر في
هذه الحملات الانتخابيه ولكن هذا يوم
انتخابي بدون شك مره بكل هدوء وكل
التصريحات تقول فيما يتعلق سؤالك عن اذا
فازت المعارضه واذا فازت الموالاه دائما
ما كنا نسال اذا كان سيحصل اعمال عنف يبدو
ان المعلومات يعني الكل مرتاحون الى انه
يعني لا لن تحصل احداث عنف الا اذا اتضح
غير ذلك في الساعات المقبله اذا كان في
هناك يعني اتهامات بالتزوير او طعون او
الى ما هنالك ولكن نبدا الكل يقول انه حتى
من مسؤولي حزب العداله والتنميه حتى
الرئيس نفسه حتى مسؤولي حزبه حتى مسؤوليه
بلديات وكلهم يقولون سنسلم السلطه لانه
هذا يوم الديمقراطيه هو يوم الرابع عشر من
مايو نحن جئنا بالديمقراطيه وسنسلم
بالديمقراطيه هذا خطابهم لنرى
الجزيره لكم طاهر بركه من اسطنبول خربوش
من اتاي فاطمه فهد من انقره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات